son you're special you were born to do
great things
you know what they were right
you
what is going on guys and girls it's
ghostrobo and welcome to bioshock the
collection one of the most incredible
franchises in gaming history resurrected
and revitalized in full 1080p up to 60
frames per second and they packed all
three games in bioshock 1 2 and infinite
and those will be coming on September
13th here in North America and September
16th everywhere else we're starting off
with the original BioShock because that
is the game that really has defined my
gaming career my gaming life and now we
get to play it again on modern consoles
swimming straight out of the wreckage to
the lighthouse there's a certain Majesty
seeing this game done up in such an
amazing an amazing new look and they've
added some effects to certain scenes
they've made everything all pretty it's
almost like they've they've spliced the
game to give it a prettier look a
prettier face and boy does it look good
so we are going to play through some of
it jump around and show you some of the
iconic moments they've added directors
commentary videos with jeff healey and
ken levine which will be awesome to
watch maybe we'll find one of those in
this video and just reimburse ourselves
in rapture which has to be my favorite
game world of all time and there's
always a lighthouse so that is where we
begin entering the golden doors of
Andrew Ryan's domain no gods or kings
the only man in the face of a real real
interesting man stares down upon us
you'll notice
that everything has a real new sheen to
it I played the game back in the summer
of two thousand seven I just moved
transferred schools and it really made a
huge mark I don't know if I've told this
story fully before but I really it
should be bioshock 2 starting YouTube
that was the game that made me so
interested in games at a level where i
was listening to podcasts and reading
every magazine review and now here we
are today almost a decade later the
collections out coming out and we get to
play it I'm getting to play it here at
2k actually they were kind enough to fly
me out to novato to their studios and
check out the game which is incredible
surreal moment for me because it's
probably my favorite game of all time
and getting to play the brand new
collection at 2k I don't think it could
be any more perfect I am Andrew Ryan and
i'm here to ask you a question is a man
not entitled to the sweat of his brow no
this is the man Washington it belongs to
the poor no sister man in the Vatican it
belongs to God no says the man in Moscow
it belongs to everyone I rejected those
answers instead I chose something
different I chose the impossible I chose
here it is and all of its glory there's
two moments for me that are like chill
inducing moments the rising above the
clouds into Colombian bioshock infinite
in the opening of the bathysphere window
here in rapture you'll notice that
Andrew Ryan ordered a new shipment of
jellyfish those were not in the original
added for just some extra detail and
really making this as perfect of a
version of Bioshock 1 as they possibly
could
this is someone
you
after that incredibly eerie scream we
jump ahead to the first plasmid and this
moment is one of the ones that let you
know that bioshock was not an ordinary
shooter if you didn't know already by
the super creepy bathysphere the
disfigured screaming splicer you knew
you were getting something good when you
first approached the gatherers garden
this little fish looks like he just had
his cherry popped wonder if you still
got some Adam let's [ __ ] quick doll wig
shopper these little fish i love
talented we're not paying that yellow
always had been lonely no better off
with metal daddy little fish see you
floating
look mr. bubbles angel I can see light
coming from his belly any minute he's
still breathing it's all right I know
he'll be an angel sing now that we've
been magically modified we're ready to
go into the the game proper the combat
begins here as we see the creepy masks
and the Menace's that lie beneath the
service the splicer serve as the base
enemies that define rapture but the big
data you just saw is probably the
coolest part a roaming boss that we will
have to deal with more than one so let's
take this guy out before he even has a
chance to say hello I've also got a
lecture bolt and a lot of the fun of the
game is mixing the plasmids with the
weaponry and using guns your mail a
wrench and the different elemental
abilities to take out anyone that tries
to approach a lot of collection is well
gathering all sorts of resources ammo
health Eve what refills our plasmids and
exploring ever increasingly creepy areas
and corpses and corners have a city gun
all wrong it started out beautiful and
you learn plenty more as you go of how
of how it just all went terribly
terribly wrong and will make it go
terribly wrong for these guys with a
little uh little water fun don't try
that at home party hats for everyone
except these two and it's really cool
for me because like i said i played
bioshock back in the day and now i'm
really impressed with how good it
actually looks like it feels like hey
we're playing a new bioshock on modern
consoles and everything feels like
totally
normal totally natural the the character
models even the hands of our character
the environments themselves it all looks
like you'd expect for something in 2016
hello that's the deadly once you punch
the electro bolt and the wrench as we
work our way through the bathrooms here
hey Carrie Otto the genetic material
that keeps the wheels of rapture tana
everybody wants us everybody needs
baby there is mr. bubbles and his
nickname may sound cute but he's
anything but destroying this poor
splicer all in efforts to protect the
little sister and that tag team is so
critical to this storyline in this game
and I cannot wait to play more of it
I'll have an extended look of Bioshock 1
on my channel and unedited version as
well as videos highlighting bioshock two
and bioshock infinite if you're curious
to see what those look like here is part
of the collection these poor people
won't get to see it but you will thanks
so much for joining us and checking out
Bioshock 1 all done up fancy and fine in
2016 here there's one of those directors
commentary we can pick up and get some
more insider information and insight
from from ken Levine himself and
continue this magical quest thank you
guys girls so much for watching hope you
enjoyed a glimpse into rapture whether
you've been here before or this is your
first time in the city it is an amazing
and incredible journey and I cannot wait
to continue more so until then thanks
again for watching drink some hot
chocolate and we will see you all light
you